good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Thursday hope
everyone's having a great day it's a
great day Jax is back in studio wearing
a cardigan that I gave to her that
apparently she doesn't hate it's a
cleared again yes she gave me this
cardigan and the second wave the second
wave of Cardigan that one's giving like
college professor at a New England ivy
league oh no they're not nearly this
fabulous turdy no but it's giving like
older gentlemen I think it's giving
student
I think of Scott giving college student
as a perhaps it's giving Ta on the track
to Professor no it's a little Collegiate
Collegiate for sure in the shooting
category I think okay I mean it's mine
I'm not insult it's not insulting if
it's mine but you look great
thanks and you're giving like 2018 toast
2018 it's right here no I know but like
I just feel like I'm used to looking at
this every day but when I see the print
in action I'm like those were the days
forgive me for trying to create Synergy
as this is from one of our sponsors
today that I will be discussing in the
latter half of the show so it's like if
you were to stand in front of the wall
you'll disappear because I'm so tiny
it's because you're so tiny yeah
um today's Thursday it's our last in
studio
episode of the week tomorrow's episode
is audio only kind of our version of a
summer Friday if you will it is because
it's a holiday weekend and this sweater
is also giving a little July 4th a
little yes it is a little red white and
blue ah the best weekend of the year and
today this year falls on a Tuesday which
is interesting yeah because they have to
give us like 12 days off right they they
have no choice so there's like if you if
you have a summer Friday a lot of people
work from home on Friday so you get like
Friday Saturday Sunday Monday too but
you're not gonna go into work on Monday
when July 4th is Tuesday what a waste
but then next year very interesting I
think the best possible day for the you
know the working woman that July 4th
could fall on is a Wednesday because
either you go Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday or
Friday Saturday Sunday Monday Tuesday
Wednesday you know you could do the back
half or the LA or the front half for
sure but like everyone kind of has to be
in agreement on what we're gonna do
we'll figure it out next year
I'm leaning towards Wednesday Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday I would agree
and then also that means you get a
little of the Tuesday before July 4th
Eve nobody's working on the July 4th
it's interesting it sucks when a holiday
falls on like a Saturday oh it's so not
worth it but that'll happen in like five
years yeah but you know what
there's two-sevenths of times where it
falls on the weekend there's five
sevenths of time there's two sevenths
but kind of three sevens because it
falls on a Friday it's not like amazing
it's just Friday Saturday Sunday
I could talk endlessly about holidays
like add it to Claudia's list of
favorite things I wonder if there's like
a committee or a department in
government that like
besides like does Holiday
Logistics yeah there I think it's us
like the way we talk about it we should
be paid for our time
there's so much time thinking about it I
feel like literally everyone with a job
does like they're always thinking about
what holiday is coming up and like how
to maximize the time off yeah and that's
why thanksgiving's such a great holiday
because it's like a dedicated day it's
always Thursday and you know you're
getting four days plus a little
Wednesday night
and you can count on that and that
Thanksgiving I mean let's keep talking
about holidays Thanksgiving is just an
amazing holiday I don't have one
complaint about Thanksgiving I love the
time of year I love the aesthetic it's
like very autumnal folklore Vibes I love
Thanksgiving it's one of my favorites
yeah I agree so I guess you could say
like a holiday falling on a Thursday is
good too yeah you could say that so
Friday is the only dicey day Saturday
and Sunday too that sucks like imagine
Thanksgiving was on a Saturday and like
it just wasn't special
I'd like to meet the man and shake his
hand who decided Thursdays would be I
think it's because Thanksgiving Thursday
we're thankful throwback Thursday
Thanksgiving I think it was kind of like
a branding thing which I love an
alliteration I wouldn't mind if it was
Thanksgiving though
because then we'd get Wednesday off too
yeah and Tuesday night you know and
while we're at it Thanksgiving what
about Thanksgiving it wouldn't work
because I mean only of Monday off
and we have so many holidays like that
so it's our nice Memorial Day right but
they're complaining but they're no
Thanksgiving they're no Thanksgiving
either no that's Friday I'm sure yeah
but it's funny how they don't like have
a Federal holiday that's always on a
Wednesday right and maybe if everybody
started celebrating Thanksgiving
we could talk about it baby
friendsgiving could become but that's an
official holiday but we're already off
oh it's a Friday before no thanksgivings
are always the week like the things the
Thursday before people do it like the
week before Oh is there really that much
hoopla and
rules yeah like yeah there is it's
people saying structure people take
friends giving really seriously maybe
I'm just bitter because like I don't
have any friends but Thanksgiving is
giving sadness
friendsgiving is giving Valentine's and
I'm good as much as I want more holidays
I don't want those no I completely agree
don't invite me to your gals 10 times
galentine's birthday birthday I can't
talk
but don't invite her to your Valentine's
birthday don't don't my birthday is
coming up I haven't even really been
speaking about it I'm so mature you
haven't been speaking on it no I didn't
want to come on here today to talk about
it no but speaking of people who like
came on to talk about do we have a story
today about Colleen no because
I like it oh because it's like just so
diffusing it's deep in our culture not
versed enough in her history and then
like all the stuff that's happening now
I've seen some things I've read some
articles you've sent me some videos but
I still not enough for me to like form
an opinion about this person I don't
know her no same I don't really know
what the back story is but all I know is
that Colleen who does like Miranda sings
She's Like an OG YouTuber he's like
found herself in like some sort of
Scandal and as YouTubers do they went
online to make a video about it and she
took a different approach it definitely
feels like something I might do where
she sat down with a ukulele and sang her
her apology slash non-apology it wasn't
an apology she was addressing things
right
um and it was truly one of the weirdest
things I've ever seen it was like a 10
minute song and she was also like acting
and then she like stopped but then she
started again and I commend her because
you know the apology addressing video
it's it's a tale as old as time it's
almost formulaic at this point where it
doesn't feel like the person is really
like they're just doing it to do they're
a hostage right in a crisis so I commend
her for taking a different route if it
didn't send a chill of cringe down my
spine I would commend her more but I
think I actually I like the approach
that she took one because it's she's
trying something that's different
different and two because it really it's
a pretty smart tactic it's very
distracting and now we're just talking
about like the cringe what a weird video
not what she did that's actually very
allegedly that's very true
so I like it because why I like it and I
like that we have a great show today we
didn't do your toasters yesterday
because we had a guest and I just wanted
the guests to be able to like you know
speak their truth yeah and so we have
deer toasters today we've got great
stories and it's just like a gorgeous
Thursday except on my way to work today
I walked and there was all this curve
like a kerfuffle on the corner and I was
like what is going on always find
yourself in a kerfuffle I know I'm kind
of like a woman of the streets you know
I'm the Forest Gump of kerfuffles 100 I
run towards drama and there were all
these people there were fire trucks and
then I turned the corner and I saw that
Tiffany's the iconic Fifth Avenue
location the flagship store which has
been under renovation for like three
years and just reopened like their new
fancy facility was literally in Flames
there was like tons of fire trucks smoke
pouring out everywhere everyone was
standing around filming so
yeah sorry to them hope everyone's okay
I hope everyone's okay but like my God
they literally James no actually to
smoke just smoke but they did open a
restaurant in the new they redid the
whole thing revamped it it took many
years and now they have a restaurant and
I have this Cafe I have to imagine that
perhaps it started in the restaurant
that's a good theory almost anyone was
just like striking matches in the
jewelry display section
maybe someone lit a cigarette but you
heard it here first Tiffany is a blaze
yeah they're still working on it oh you
when you got yeah I had I was rerouted
that took me forever to get here crazy
times New York I couldn't like get out
and walk because of the smoke because no
because I'm not like in Walking form
form 100 so crazy you heard it here
first woman on the streets I got
interviews with everyone and what were
they saying did you get the cause no
everyone was really standing around
filming like it was so so ridiculous it
is but like I was too and I felt like so
dumb how long did you stay there to film
10 10 seconds okay then that's fine it's
like it's like the kind of thing I'm
like oh my God everyone was filming and
I was like damn wait the people need to
know gotta film but like I have an
audience of people like I'm Different I
I do have a duty because I had coffee
for breakfast
you have a duty to do I have a duty to
do daru which is what we're about to do
how is do Dadu Theo's doing well really
doing well
um putting the family on his back
being a ray of sunshine it takes its
toll it does but he handles it with such
Grace you would never know the pressures
that he's under you would never know
what's going on behind the scenes yeah I
saw him yesterday I saw Bruno yesterday
and he was looking fine as ever yeah
those walks when he goes out on his
walks that's like me time for Thea like
he recharges his battery so that he can
continue to give and give and give and
and we can continue to take and take and
take yeah that's beautiful yeah it's the
cycle of life
should we dive in I guess so stories are
there's a lot to know today but it's
like I don't know that it's gonna be
like
well I haven't heard them yet so I'll
see what I can come up with come up with
you know you'll see you'll see it's just
like news you know yeah so without
further Ado here are the fast five
stories that are news that you need to
know
and today's episode is brought to you by
mattress firm mattress firm has a huge
selection of mattresses from America's
top brands at every price point Mattress
Firm has their own brand of mattresses
and accessories also called sleepies so
that you know when you're going into a
mattress firm like you're getting the
best of the best creme de La Creme top
tier what does that mean though when you
say creme de La Creme oh I'm so glad you
asked it actually means cream it's very
confusing cream of the cream cream of
the cream cream of the crop actually I
think it means
um so the Sleep Experts from Mattress
Firm tapped into their over 200 hours of
training and experience helped millions
of customers get the rest that they need
by creating a best-selling line of
mattresses pillows bedding and
protectors I just got new pillows from
Mattress Firm from their sleep experts
pillows are very personal and that's why
it's like nice to talk to somebody an
expert because Ben also we can't just
get one pillow for the whole bed been
like soft I like more firm we have
different needs Ben likes to sleep with
one pillow I like to sleep with two so
the Sleepy's Coconut Bliss pillow has
tons of features that help give you a
great night's rest the aromatherapy and
gentle fragrance have made this pillow a
customer favorite they have memory foam
to conform to your head and neck for
proper alignment for relaxing pressure
relief and a soothing Support also they
have more airflow so if you love the
cold side of a pillow this one is for
you sleeping on the right pillow and
Mattress is so important and waking up
well rested makes everything more clear
so Mattress Firm is just the place for
everything bed everyone knows that
they're the best for the best and the
right mattress matters find yours with
mattress firm's July 4th sale which is
happening right now shop in store or
online at mattressfirm.com I mean we
love holidays for so many reasons and
one of them is the sales and honestly I
mattress room is a couple really good
sales a year that's where I got my
mattress like four years ago and the
July 4th sale is not to be missed
today's episode is also brought to you
by the perfect bar the original
refrigerated protein bar that you know
we love if you haven't heard perfect bar
just launched a new line of protein bars
called perfect bar layers perfect bar
layers are a new line of crispy protein
bars stacked with three delicious with
delicious layers and made with whole
food nutrition they're made with Crispy
base of peanut and cashew butter layered
with dark chocolate or hundred percent
real fruit and then they're sprinkled
with toasted gluten-free oats they're
packed with up to 11 grams of protein
and they come in two delicious flavors
the first is crispy peanut butter and
chocolate and the second is crispy
peanut butter and Berry which is
basically like a healthy peanut butter
and jelly because they're made with
whole food ingredients they're classic
blend of 20 organic superfoods and they
contain no artificial preservatives
perfect bar layers are stored in the
fridge so you could say that these bars
are stacked and packed if you aren't
convinced already they're also non-GMO
project verified they're gluten-free soy
free kosher and low GI the best part is
that you can now find them in the
refrigerated section at Targets
Nationwide you know we love a perfect
bar we keep them here at the studio I
keep them at my house Ben loves them
throw them in your purse and when you
like crash in the middle of the day
you'll get a bar that's delicious that
keeps you full it's full of protein it's
just always good to have on hand they
also know that it'll be Love At First
Bite with the perfect bar so they're
offering you a chance to try their new
refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
text upload a picture of your receipt
from your local grocery store and
they'll reimburse you for the cost of
one bar it'll go directly into your
venmo or your PayPal account which is
pretty cool all you have to do is go to
perfect snacks.com toast to get that
free perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today happy snacking thank you
Claudia and welcome also not to get
sidetracked because I know the stories
are waiting for us but you had your book
club last night I did it was a great
success it was so we I drove you know
I've been talking about that for like
how were the Dynamics in the car well
they were really good until Abe got in
the car and we realized he was so quiet
and I turned around and he's reading
because he didn't finish the book which
is like a big No-No you know come on
like finish the book and I understand it
was 700 pages and if I can finish it
anyone can that's true also just reading
in a car is a crazy thing to do uh I
read in cars I could never I wish I
could I'd be so much more well read yeah
I read it like all the time in cars and
I mean you could have put on the audio
tape for him and could have all listened
but like we had to do it you have to do
it you know it was every man for
themselves yeah but how did the book go
over without a hit without a oh the book
went over the group was divided mixed
reviews well we were uh operating on a
smaller book club two of our members
couldn't come so five out of seven and
three of us loved two of us did not like
which sparked interesting debate yeah
um but something crazy we went to the
suburbs one of our members lives in New
Jersey we crossed Interstate lines and
the craziest thing happened so we all
left
me and
Abe are like close to the car in the
driveway and Margo and Rachel are like
saying goodbye to Raquel whose house it
was like so they're like in the yard I
would say there's about 20 feet between
us
and literally it's Pitch Black
right behind Rachel and Margo probably
three feet behind them the biggest deer
you've ever seen in your life but it was
behind them they didn't know I literally
you know when you're so like freaky kids
and like
[Music]
I couldn't speak dear and they turn
around and the deer is chilling like not
deer are supposed to be afraid of human
no they're walking he's getting closer
yeah Margo and Rachel are beelining they
made it to the car safely no one seemed
like as like scared as I was and I
wasn't even in imminent danger which is
so crazy it's so dirty and then I ended
up having a nightmare about a lion
um near Olivia's House who was like
obsessed with me and kept like breaking
into their house to like cuddle with me
it was it was definitely connected to
the deer incident for sure but maybe
like sprinkled with a bit of Theo's
subconscious yeah actually the way the
lion kind of circled and then plopped
down on my legs was supposed to
yeah but I was pretty scarred so what
you're saying is the Deer Run This Town
yeah well in New Jersey in New York the
rats around this town I guess in New
Jersey the Deer Run This Town
doesn't sound so bad it was kind of a
beautiful deer yeah but it was just like
this huge animal it was crazy
yeah so much drama the book club is
always causing drama
don't they always yeah and you know like
the point of a book club I feel like
people join a book club they think it's
like you know a nice social some social
activity but like book clubs they're
just also looking for a bit of drama I
feel like it's really the whole point
yeah
our book club doesn't have like actual
drama but I'm always trying to find an
angle you know yeah well you should
choose a book that would be really
divisive yeah find like the weak spot of
the book club and exploit it yeah I just
really why I love my book club it's
because I always do good last time I
made like such a good home cooked meal
we had spaghetti we had salmon we had uh
potatoes so when you have it at your
place what do you guys eat so actually I
haven't hosted yet
everyone loves to host it's not like oh
who's hosting this month that's why we
call ourselves the balabusta book club
because we're all like real Homemakers
except for me so there's never been like
oh damn where are we gonna do it this
month you know next month we've got two
people fighting oh Natalie wants to do
it and Abe wants to do it
so until there's like a drought then
I'll be like okay I'll do it but so far
it's not slim picking what would you
cook would you have Ben prepare
something it depends it depends on like
where I'm at that week like busy wise
either I'd have been cook I would have
like a caterer or I would just order in
kosher food okay yeah yeah I thought you
were gonna say or you would try and cook
[__] no no it's like literally not even
an option no no I would have like
pre-prepared from like a park east or
like a kosher grocer yeah yeah no I'm
not cooking beautiful but so far
nobody's asked
I also love the book club because it
gives me such good father for the
podcast
totally that's like the redheads new
episode drops next week it's been so
long since there's been a redhead it has
been because the first Thursday of July
is like in the July 6th I think because
maybe the first day is like a Wednesday
that happens sometimes and it's really
nice we get a lot of extra time and we
recorded our June episode a week early
because of Memorial Day so we literally
had like six weeks in between episodes
I've never read so many books maybe
share at the end like how much we read
uh in the off season I've never had this
many like I'm a little embarrassed no
way we do that in our book club too it's
like what at the end we're like what
else did everyone read this month I read
eight books this month I'm like I read
nine it's crazy crazy also those [__]
Freedom McFadden sneak up on you she's
also so quick yeah like I have three
Freedom patterns yep
what can you do nothing nothing so let's
get into the stories the top story of
the day is that Madonna was rushed to
the hospital she's been intubated in the
ICU after being found unresponsive now
what does intubated mean like in a tube
oh a tube yeah like she's helped
breathing oh man I was thinking like
a hyperbaric chamber no no oh intimated
that's like what they put coveted
patients on right like respirator Vibes
Vibes but I think it's more for the
lungs damn yeah did they say why
um there's like some things going on her
um manager had said that she developed a
serious bacterial infection which led to
a several day stay in the ICU I saw a
headline that she's been rehearsing for
her tour she had like 12 days of like
non-stop
um
going
going and practicing and whatnot but to
be intubated that sounds like the
exhaustion right you get like
dehydration you go for like you you can
go to the hospital but it's not like I
see you right and she was found
unresponsive damn
um and then taken to the hospital so it
sounds very serious it does but also
they obviously kept this under wraps
because
she's like now it it's not like I feel
like sometimes we get the news it's like
Madonna found unresponsive and then we
wait days to hear what happened yeah
like she was able to keep this private
and then her manager was able to tell
everyone when they were sort of Out of
the Woods yeah because it was Saturday
that she was rushed to the hospital oh
and today's what Thursday so yeah so
she's now out of the ICU but she's still
under Medical Care and full recovery is
expected I wonder if she'll still go on
tour
it depends what happened like what
actually happened yeah I wouldn't be
surprised if there's more to the story
than what they feel comfortable sharing
and that's totally fine
um
but that's really scary
um quick question about speaking about
tours do we have lizzo as a story today
no so things got cut some there are
stories on The Cutting Room floor I do
quickly want to talk about did you see
what happened with lizzo I saw no I I
saw a headline but lizzo went to see
Beyonce and then she like of course was
like so like obsessed she went on her
Instagram or her Tick Tock and made like
a couple videos just about how amazing
it was and the real key message of what
she had said was like what Beyonce's
doing is so like incomprehensible and
she's not even gonna be um like
appreciated in her own time like years
and years in the future like we will be
able to really understand what Beyonce
was doing like the most popular thing
right now pales in comparison to
Beyonce's tour and it did feel you know
very pointed because Beyonce and Taylor
are really on the same tour right now
they're playing the same venues in the
same countries at the same level with
the same amount of people but Taylor's
tour has really overtaken The Narrative
I don't really see like a ton of stories
or
um
chatter about Beyonce's tour it's like
they're both equally as impressive but
something about Taylor's tour has just
gotten you know the media and and the
fans talking more and so it was it felt
like what lizzo was saying was
definitely like a little bit of a slight
at Taylor the most popular person right
now like won't even compare to what we
all really when we've all finally
understand what Beyonce's doing so it
felt pointed did she say what Beyonce is
doing or just you know she was speaking
Yeah Yeah she was speaking vaguely okay
um
and then I do believe she had to end up
um deactivating her Twitter because the
swifties came after her and you know the
swifties can be deeply unwell and they
were like you know being inappropriate
about like her body and I think it got
like racist so
um
it was an interesting Saga I think the
conversation though like I I do think I
actually do think that lizzo doesn't
like Taylor Swift because there's like
been one other time she was on live with
sizza and Taylor came up and it was
right after the Grammys
um and scissor was like kind of gushing
about Taylor
um because Taylor's like a big fan of
Susan I think Taylor like beelined for
sizza at the Grammys to like you know
fawn over her and lizzo just like stayed
quiet like literally just stayed quiet
that's so interesting and I do feel like
if they did get along there would be
examples that we could cite of like you
know them interacting interacting but
you know what not everyone has to get
along agreed and and in real life a lot
of people don't get along so yeah
celebrities are like so phony like they
get along with everyone like it's funny
it's phony so I'm totally fine with them
not getting along
um it does feel like a pointed message
but I also feel like Taylor is doing all
the things that she's doing and of
course people are obsessed with her but
she also like knows how to like Market
Market and drive headlines and
everything like even this the two
different songs every it's a marketing
thing yeah it's marketing and that's
what she does and like they're just like
her and Beyonce are just different
people like Beyonce's just like doing
her show also Beyonce started her tour
or internationally and Taylor started
her her tour in America and then they're
literally going to swap like next year
is when Beyonce comes we'll be hearing
all about Beyonce and Taylor that you
follow are going to Beyonce's tour and
all the celebrities are going to be
going right it's yeah I think they're
going to swap in terms and I I'm sure it
was done on purpose like I'm sure Taylor
knew that Beyonce was planning a tour
and Beyonce knew that Taylor was
planning a tour and they probably had to
like fight for dates so one of them
choosing to start internationally was
clearly like a decision yeah
so it just looks interesting
and like when Taylor's International
I don't think we're gonna be following
out like every
Secret Song and all the guests yeah
everything so while I think the swifties
like really need to calm down like
I do Wonder like what lizzo's thing with
Taylor is
yeah because that like live stream with
her and sizza like she was literally she
just shot like Liz says it was set did I
say Liza I know but you almost did
Giselle was just like like gushing over
Taylor and lizzo did not move
or respond interesting fact toy yeah
are you ready for our next story a
little more medical news Pete Davidson
is in rehab but is expected out pretty
soon so Pete Davidson has checked into
treatment people has confirmed a source
close to the SNL Alum tells people he's
in rehab but he should be getting out
pretty soon he said to be receiving
inpatient therapy to address issues
related to post-traumatic traumatic
stress disorder and his prior borderline
personality diet disorder diagnosis
according to the initial report by Page
Six a source close to him said people
often check himself into rehab to work
on these issues his friends and family
have been supportive during this time
he's been very open about his mental
health yeah struggles
um
and we've reported he's had some not
great moments moments and uh the car
crash Behavior recently so I think this
comes out the voicemail what voicemail
that he left for PETA oh oh yeah yeah
yeah like it was funny but it was
unhinged mostly the car crash was just
bizarre very bizarre so I'm glad he's
getting the help that he needs it seems
like he goes to rehab like it's like a
tune-up for him and yeah it's something
that he'll constantly have to keep doing
keep up with
um because it did seem like he was not
at his best place yeah but it also feels
like for the last few weeks like since
the pita thing he's been very quiet it's
like him getting treatment like makes
sense timeline wise yeah if he's almost
done
yeah I don't know how long treatment me
neither
but wishing him well I wonder if him and
Chase Stewie wonders are still together
I I think that they are this article
still calls her his girlfriend and
they've been together for like a long
time yeah and she's not the typical girl
like he's been seen with back to back
over the last few years he always went
with someone like older more famous kind
of Buzzy and she I think they worked on
something together she's not like crazy
famous at all yeah um and I think
they're probably really well suited for
each other they're both like low-key
well I don't know her very well but I
hope that she's a good influence on him
yeah which it does in her personal life
so true that's so true good call so
wishing him well everyone is you know
Fallen ill I know that's what the
stories are yeah that's what I'm saying
yeah
are you ready for our next story you
don't have a hot take on Pete going to
rehab no I don't think he needs it
that that I do think that he needs it or
I think he doesn't need it you think
that he should stay spiraling no is that
your hot tape no no that's I've said
like I'm glad he's catching it before it
gets like yeah there was obviously some
erratic Behavior happening and now he's
getting help yeah I'm happy for him know
how to take know how to take I support
him you do as a person like I I want the
best for him yeah you know yeah are you
ready for our next story yeah which is
some really sweet family news because
John Legend has shared a photo with his
four kids after Chrissy Teigen revealed
yesterday that they welcomed secretly
another baby via surrogate but the story
was so confusing to me at first because
I'm like yeah we know she just like
people notification Chrissy Teigen
welcomes a new child I'm like yeah we
know people we know we know so Chrissy
Teigen had a baby five months ago and
then I guess just uh this week they
welcomed a baby via surrogate on June
19th okay so 10 days ago
um named Ren a son and then they still
have their their two older children
miles Luna what was the the third q and
ren cute so family of four now and she
put like a whole statement on her
Instagram explaining like they had after
she lost her her baby they did a
surrogate and it didn't take she wanted
twins she really always wanted four kids
and it didn't take but then she did IVF
like there was a million things going on
at once and two things actually happened
to stick and I think that like they
loved this surrogate that they had met
and I think their baby is middle name is
actually for the surrogate Ben Alexandra
or Alexander and then the surrogate's
name is Alexandra which is really sweet
um so that's so nice for them so nice
for them and you know what I had an
interesting thought because Christy has
a five month old and I think she's
breastfeeding and so I wonder if she'll
be able to breastfeed the new baby for
sure how nice is that that is nice like
little life hack yeah that by the way
definitely if she wants oh did she say
she's breastfeeding no I I didn't see
anything about it I was just like
thinking about it because also like
there's this photo of her breastfeeding
SD
I don't know how old the baby is here
not five months right but if she is
still breastfeeding she can but I'm sure
she thought about that that's called
tandem feeding that's insane a kid on
each titty damn if you were still
breastfeeding Harry which you're not but
like some people do go what is he 15
months 16 yeah like some people do you
know we all Saw Game of Thrones so would
you tandem
what do you mean oh if Harry was still
breastfeeding so well it's also
complicated to breastfeed during a
pregnancy like oh is it yeah um
typically you can do it and people do it
and I have no
like if you're doing it I think that's
awesome but um some doctors recommend
like stopping at a certain point
because it can like induce labor oh to
you know some people actually like
people use their breast pump if they're
trying to go into labor oh like it's
like one of the things
spicy foods side effects yeah doing that
interesting I mean Harry's teeth are
literally the craziest thing I've ever
seen in my ninth they're so [__]
sharp yeah one time he accidentally bit
me I swear to God I had to go to the
hospital like their things
I would not let that near your your
nipple yeah so would I tandem feed like
at the same time probably not
logistically be too hard especially with
like a newborn they're so like tiny and
Harry's enormous right and maybe I would
like do it once to like just try it as a
new experience but also Harry being as
old as he is he would probably if he
were still breastfeeding would only be
like once or twice a day whereas the
baby would be eating like eight times a
day so it's just like it's not gonna
work no I'm okay but it's like when you
have twins that's what you do right
uh you know the twin twins is the dream
for me
um even though I know like the year
maybe two years like after like would be
the worst like like the hardest and I
was thinking like okay
do you need two different nurseries when
you have twins because like what if one
of them wakes up and starts crying and
then the other one wakes up yeah so like
no you don't need two different
nurseries I do wonder about them waking
each other up but like you have to
remember like they've been together for
10 months like to separate them it's
giving three identical strangers but you
can't put two twins in the same bassinet
or the same crib I
have twins in the
great like
the town is big enough for the two of us
but it might just be like because it
looks nice and it sounds nice but like
the American Pediatric Association says
no I think you do wind up getting like
two bassinets and then when they're
bigger you get two cribs but maybe like
they hang out in the same bassinet
because they want that warmth of your
twin I used to like I think like when I
was a kid and I was like very
self-absorbed I used to think like being
a twin was the worst thing that could
have like if I was a twin like I would
not be okay like sharing everything
sharing the spotlight but now as an
adult who like is gonna have children
one it's awesome for the mom and two
like what's better
than having like a built-in best friend
like two of my best friends one who's in
the book club Anna doesn't read but
Rachel does
um they're like best friends they live
in the same building they like are one
of them has baby another one's having a
baby like it's so they work together
like what's better sounds like us it
does sound like us so I feel like you've
had a lot of the twin experience and I
do feel like if you were an actual twin
like a born twin like you wouldn't you
couldn't see it the way no no no not at
all you couldn't possibly be as like
Lively as you are like because you would
you share more so like balancing off
another person yeah I just think like
every new life experience would be so
much easier not that that came off as
saying like twins don't aren't Lively
but like you know like I know what you
mean you know what I mean like you would
always be a half yeah of a of a unit of
a unit which has enormous benefits yes
like going to a new school starting camp
like you have a friend like you're not
like feeling awkward yeah
because it's also like siblings I felt
that way so many times like with Olivia
yeah but like even with you and Olivia
like starting a new camper starting in
the school like you're different grades
yes you know when we start a new school
we were different grades that was
actually hard but when we started a new
camp we just like requested each other
on our like you know when they put you
in the same boat do you know anyone and
so I was like molivia and they put us in
the same bunk which was crazy because
we're not thinking we're twins yes when
before we came to Camp they were like oh
the two Usher girls had her in the same
bunk like they're two cuddly twins yeah
and we were not
um but it worked out nice yeah
very nice yeah I still want to have
twins I'll take quintuplets okay but
I've been sending you I get like I know
oh did you see what I sent you like yeah
like the actual stomach no and then also
like the after effects like it's really
hard it moves all your organs and like
your abdominal wall and that woman that
I sent you is she was in a lot of pain
damn years later oh and then uh her she
wasn't I forget where she was from but
her captions weren't in English and so I
was reading them via translate and it
didn't translate I didn't understand
everything but she said like there's a
surgery for it but like sometimes the
surgery like it's still painful damn
like nobody talks about that yeah she
was gonna be on like if she was like
Swedish or something she was gonna be on
a TV program about it how exciting yeah
first time I was ever on television was
on a Swedish TV program
it sounds like they have great
programming sounds like they do
interesting stuff
anyways congratulations to the legend
Teague yeah that's really nice it's so
crazy how like literally in a few months
you go from being a family of three to a
family of five
in a few months ago from being a family
of oh sorry yeah I thought you meant
kids wise exactly two to four no sorry
family of four to a family of six yeah
that's crazy yeah
and I'm happy for them that's crazy to
have a sibling that would be five years
five months younger than you oh you're
in the same grade but you're not twins
yeah that's crazy they would call that
Irish twins but this is not Irish twins
what's Irish twins when they would be
from the same gestational carrier say
mother but they do have the same mother
but like getting pregnant and then
getting pregnant like immediately after
having two kids within one year okay
that's not the same and not the same as
this this is crazy like they're gonna be
in the same grade and everything but
they won't be twins yeah that's crazy
but like if you gave birth and then like
say a month later got pregnant again and
then like that I know that's Irish twins
I get it cool yeah
are you ready for our next story yeah
Bravo is planning a Vanderpump Rules
spin-off with Jax Kristen and Brittany
says her report so Bravo's reportedly
working out of Vanderpump Rules spin off
according to a deadline report published
on Wednesday the new show is said to
include former cast members Jax Taylor
Brittany Cartwright and Kristen Doty
while deals have yet not been confirmed
the hour reported that the new reality
series will feature an eight-episode
season that's so little yeah I guess
it's a test yeah I mean um I think
people have been talking about this for
so long there was before everyone got
fired there was like a lot of rumors
about Valley Village becoming its own
show and everyone having kids maybe like
all the moms being on One show and I do
think with the new like kind of
Renaissance of Vanderpump Rules the more
content the better but I do think this
particular show like really needs Stasi
yeah do you talk to her about it a
little bit like on the toast I don't
think that I did I she I talked about
her return to reality TV and he said it
depends on the show yeah I asked her if
it was completely off the table and she
said no like she does miss it and she's
still like built for it and she still is
this huge fan base
um and I don't know if that means like
her own show but I do think like this
would probably be a good return for him
there is like drama there like between
her Jax and Brittany and her and Beau we
like never really got a lot of Bo and Bo
such like an integral part of her
podcast and her tour and her fans love
him so I actually feel like this is
probably like the right move for her but
I don't know if she'll do it yeah I
agree especially now they have like all
have kids they need like the show sounds
good but they need more of course it
can't just be the three of them I'm sure
they're trying to get other people who
we know and then maybe some people that
we don't yeah like we knew of friends of
theirs who have maybe also like have
kids and live in the ballet yeah and
then like do you think that I guess
Sheena and Lala
at one point made of like Gem Ship at
one point yes but no even though like
Lala's so close to like stassi
and I think she's close with Brittany
too yeah Lala really like does fit on
this new format yeah but no no he would
never leave if they didn't leave the
sinking ship they're certainly Not Gonna
Leave You Know The Royal Caribbean right
yeah I don't know and we knew this was
coming and I think there's been so many
like rumors about this over the years
even before you know Scandal and then
you just but there's so many rumors
about Vanderpump Rules in general that I
I don't really pay much mind I think
what had happened was like before
Covenant before everyone got fired and
they were like working with like Charlie
and the new girls they did think about
making the spin-off show for like all
the married older um like OG castmates
then when everyone got fired I think it
was like whatever and then with the
Renaissance of Vanderpump Rules with
Scandal they were like wait look at look
how many people were tuning into these
podcasts with Jax Brittany stassi
Kristen like there was so much fanfare
and hype for them that now it makes
sense to bring like I think the idea has
always been there and it's been on the
table then off the table now I think
it's back on the table yeah
I'm here for it me too like say what you
want about Jax but that man is made for
television and also now all of these
people are watching old seasons of
Vanderpump Rules For the First Time
right they're falling in love with
stassi and Kristen and and you know just
feeling really passionate about these
characters like there's an audience for
them that's so true now it's like the
second wave yeah I think it's good I I'm
I would watch it 100
are you ready for our fifth and final
story yeah it's a little submersible
update it's been a few days since we've
had one but presumed human remains have
been recovered from the Titan sub
wreckage the Coast Guard says so Crews
have recovered presumed human remains
while searching through the wreckage of
the Titan submersible according to the
U.S Coast Guard medical professionals
will conduct a formal analysis of what
is believed to be human remains that
were carefully recovered within the
wreckage at the site of the incident the
Coast Guard said in the news release the
Coast Guard also said that the Marine
Board of Investigation intends to
transport the evidence aboard a U.S
Coast Guard and Qatar to a port in the
U.S where they'll be able to facilitate
further analysis and testing yeah they
got like Paparazzi footage of them like
loading out all the different pieces of
the submersible
um and I have to imagine
like it was sealed so even when it like
combust there's probably like body parts
in there now yeah I can when they
announced like that the they had found
like debris on the ocean floor and that
the thing imploded like I did not
imagine that the pieces would jump this
big yeah well at first they said it like
exploded whatever but then like I saw a
bunch of experts being like because of
the pressure it actually probably
um like compounded like I don't know
what the right word it pulls it into
itself fold it into like shrunk almost
like so and everyone would have just
like instantly been so that tracks with
what I saw but no I don't think it
exploded like to bits I was thinking to
bit for me like the word debris like we
we haven't had some conversation yeah
what debris means but to me it meant
bits yeah like shrapnel yeah like
and then it's like how do you even
recover that on the ocean floor so yeah
this like I mean I'm sure this will
bring some more peace to the families to
like have their remains found and give a
proper barrier perhaps
um I can't really imagine like what
condition
no people's bodies are no but like
it brings peace and closure right like
you can like physically lay someone to
rest yeah so sad like this whole
Saga I guess it like it really did end
in one of the better possibilities like
inter like they were like they were dead
but all the ways that they could have
died or or maybe we never even found out
like of all the ways like this is one of
the better ones like in terms of like
peace of mind yes but it's like the
saddest thing yeah
oh and I saw this morning that the
company Titan plans on like continuing
these
sort of exhibitions will there be any
changes I'm I'm sure but I can't imagine
a singular person would go now like
knowing what we all know yeah
like I imagine that the people who went
this time and all previous times like
really imagined it was a safe Excursion
but like now we know it's not so anybody
going has that understanding like this
was so sad because these people went on
what they thought was like a routine
totally safe people had done it before
made it even scarier but like now we all
know so if anyone's going like first of
all what are you doing and second of all
like you know now yeah you have the
knowledge of you might not come back
because other people haven't yeah but I
think for some Thrill Seekers and
Adventures and explorers that's always a
risk yeah
but they did but I didn't feel like this
particular group of people was like
thrill seeking you know they were like
older not necessarily thrill seeking but
explorers is the right word I guess they
were just like businessmen no but like
Hamish had done Adventures like this
before
um to the I think the father and son and
not the son but the father and then the
The French naval expert were both really
big Titanic Fanatics right
TM and then the sun was supporting his
dad yeah
terrible really terrible well we're glad
to have some closure yeah it's like a
wrap on that yeah
um should we do deer toasters let us
well deer toasters is brought to you
first by fashion pass which is actually
where my Romper is from today even
though Jackie said it's giving 2018.
I've been using toast I think it's
giving like cute summer girly swirly
with a knack for style that's what I
think and a great tan so we have been
thank you we have been fashion past
girls for years and there if there was
ever a time to sign up for fashion pass
this is it we know you have a million
weddings vacations activities this
summer and fashion pass is perfect for
that so it's a rental service where you
get unlimited clothing rentals where you
can swap out your pieces as many times a
month as you want so you know you're
only going to wear that dressed once to
a wedding or you'll think about those
vacation outfits once you get your
picture you're done and that's what
fashion pass is for they have all the
Best Brands like good American for love
and lemons beckon Bridge show me your
MooMoo these are all pieces that retail
for between 200 and 600 so when you're
renting you're getting an insane value
you save so much money because you're
not buying close all the time we are
both on the trendsetter plan so we get
four clothing items per order we can
switch out as often as we want it's not
like we have to wait till the end of the
month to return it which can be really
annoying the shipping is super fast they
take care of the dry cleaning everything
is done for you so you just send it back
in the pre-labeled bag and when you're
done you can choose new items it
couldn't be easier and the best part is
that if you find something you really
love and you want to keep it you can buy
it directly from Fashion plus which is
more sustainable but it's also on sale
because you're buying it directly from
them so it can be anywhere from 30 to 60
off we of course have a discount code
for you it is the best discount they are
offering and you're not going to want to
go anywhere else to shop if you go to
fashionpass.com toast you can use code
toast at checkout where you'll get 40
off your first month so you can try it
for just literally 49 that's unlimited
rentals for just 49 with code toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by impossible Foods so it is hot Grill
summer we're cooking we're making
Burgers dogs whatever it is that you
want and impossible Foods once you and
your girl to join them in making meat
history so as you guys may or may not
know Jax especially is a big impossible
girly impossible beef is delicious it
tastes like beef and historically
speaking beef is delicious but the fun
thing about impossible beef is that it's
made from plants so it has zero animal
hormones it has 19 grams of protein per
serving and it's better for the planet
so
this Supple I mean with July 4th coming
up I feel like everybody's getting ready
for a barbecue season and whether you
are a vegetarian a vegan we are Kosher
or you just you know eat more
sustainably and you don't want you know
animal hormones in your food and you
want to help preserve the planet there's
a million reasons to try impossible
Foods they're me quote meats are so good
perfect for July 4 doesn't even know the
difference if you want to prank them
it's so true your guests won't even know
the difference
so you can start making meat history
today just head over to the meat aisle
at your local grocery store grab some
impossible beef or patties and you can
get grilling grilling season is upon us
like
treat yourself treat the planet treat
everyone and Shop impossible Foods I
love their impossible beef and I
actually recently had on an airplane an
impossible beef burrito that was
absolutely delicious me and Margo
scarfed the whole thing down interesting
I know isn't that that does sound good
oh wait no no I can't close the iPad
it's dear toasters time our weekly
advice segment where we give advice to
the girlies the girl is in need the girl
is going through work troubles boyfriend
troubles body troubles whatever it is
you could submit two ways now we have
two different ways of submitting uh
submissions for deer toasters the first
first is if you go to the
toastpodcast.com scroll down there's a
submission box it's completely Anonymous
or you can email to your toasters
gmail.com two different ways alrighty
you ready
dear Jackson Claude every Sunday my
husband and his 70 year old best friend
go on long bike rides post bike ride my
husband makes his friend breakfast at
our home breakfast usually lasts about
two hours here's my issue during the
breakfast portion of their Sundays the
seven-year-old is walking around my
house and eating breakfast with his
shirt off wearing only small tight
biking shorts I've explained to my
husband that it's really disgusting and
neither one of us knows how to approach
a situation without hurting the elderly
man's feelings any advice would be
wonderful
so I have to imagine that his shirt is
sweaty right that's why he took it off
so your husband just offer him an old
t-shirt but maybe he's also sweaty and
like wants to dry off I get it but like
the thing is like you're really never
going to change a seven year old habit
and you can't and you it's honestly
disrespectful to try hot take she said
she wasn't gonna have many hot takes but
she does I said that's a story yes like
at 70 years old like you have to let
them be earn the right to do things the
way that he wants I do feel for you
because this would bother me as well
could they eat outside perhaps that's
nice to have a patio or a balcony
Alfresco dining and then in the winter
he'll be so cold he'll put it on the
jacket okay so that's a good option
suggest eating outside I also don't
think it would hurt to be like hey I'm
gonna grab a clean shirt want one you
know like ask yeah
is a crazy thing to do I'm not saying
this is like it's it's something only a
seven-year-old can get away with yeah
and it's gross like chest hair like it's
gross we're eating we're in the kitchen
he's just worked out and then you're
sitting on my chair like trust me I'm
with you we empathize but at some point
like seven-year-olds are gonna do their
thing and like you really can't change
their habits you know they are who they
are at this point yeah that's really a
perk of getting older people stop asking
so much of you because you're you are
who you are right
try these two options and if it doesn't
work like let go and let God like it is
what it is maybe they should start going
out for breakfast
love that Alfresco dining has potential
depends where you live yeah you riding
in from Alaska you know or Arizona both
have al fresco dining Alaska
yeah in the summer right but Arizona you
can eat outside year round but I have to
imagine if they were like if they had
like an outdoor setup like that this
wouldn't have been you know this would
have been an option months ago yeah but
try just try
all right ready hey girlies so I invited
my single friend out to go to a concert
with my husband and a group of our
friends
we are all close with one of the couples
in the group our daughters are best
friends with them we see them every week
for play dates but long story short the
wife of this couple couldn't get into
the concert because she was too drunk so
her husband sent her home in an Uber
and her husband still went to the
concert he ended up [__] my single
friend by the end of the night on my
couch then they proceeded to meet up for
breakfast the next day or sorry not the
next day the following Monday what would
you guys do should I tell my friend AKA
the wife should I keep this to myself
should I move on oh my God I just want
to say like I know it's not the point
here but like if I was ever too drunk to
get somewhere and then sent me home like
[__] take me home you're sending me in
a random Uber clearly this couple is not
in the most stable relationship right
now but I and I have like a you know
typically like you mind your own
business whatever but like really If
This Were you like think about if it
were you let me think of like okay I
have a single friend got it and you have
a couple friend
okay okay like they're not your best
friends but like they're in your life
I'm I'm picturing it and the girl went
home drunk and the husband hooked up
with your friend
what would you do I guess in this
situation my allegiance is to my friend
right like couple friends are different
than like a friend you know what I mean
yeah but like a friend who would do this
like I don't want a friend like that
honestly yeah no it's it's deplorable
I don't know I don't know
the thing is though they're it just I
feel like their relationship is not in a
great place and like
maybe she doesn't know that they cheat
right maybe they have an arrangement
because like he's kind of brazen going
for breakfast on Monday yeah you don't
just like meet a girl at a concert and
like hook up with her on your friend's
couch in plain view right for the first
time of having an affair right like when
everyone knows like you're not really
doing a good job at Keeping a Secret
it's like you don't really have a lot to
lose so either Therefore your
relationship is in a really bad place or
you have some sort of arrangement so
would you tell the friend I don't know I
think I would force the husband who I
know as a couple friend be like you tell
your wife because if you don't I will
and honestly that might be a bluff but
like you just have to like it's his
problem like he [__] the bed and why are
you cleaning it up
I think what I would do in practice like
really trying to put myself in the
situation is like I would try and talk
to the wife and get a better
understanding of like their relationship
maybe get her like maybe that's between
them and she's not gonna share with you
and that's not indicative of what's
actually going on no no but like
I might poke around first to see what
this information might would it be new
news this is like a hot potato like you
don't want it like give it to someone
else yeah but I feel like if it were me
I wouldn't be close enough with the
husband to be like you go tell her
but you know what like you have to be
assertive like you're now in this [__]
situation
your single friend
she don't give a [__] like it's not her
relationship it's really on the husband
of course it is but it like he also had
an affair like why are we expecting yeah
maybe okay maybe you tell your husband
toaster tell your husband to talk to the
husband who cheated
so you got to tell your wife or else my
wife will
okay I think that's good okay
horrible especially with the situation
I'm thinking in my mind yeah none of
these people would do it I swear like
none of these people the single girl in
my mind who I thought is like one of my
best friends from middle school I would
never think she would but I just needed
like a person you know yeah
and this couple love each other they
would never get in there but putting
myself in the situation it's it's no
bueno no I really feel for you me too
but I don't think this is one of the
situations where you can do nothing
because if they found out if the wife
found out that you knew oh my God like
you look you look like an [__] no and
also like you have to put yourself in
her situation like would you want to
like everyone knows this information
except for her I would want someone to
tell right you look stupid with with
everyone just like talking about it and
not telling you yeah yeah that's true
so I would want someone to tell me for
sure okay here's our third and final hey
Jackson charity obsessed with both of
you beyond I've never laughed as much so
much listening to your podcast and truly
feel like y'all are my friends while I'm
working from home oh my good thing
here's my dilemma I've been at my job
for a little over a year when I took
this job I really wanted the opportunity
but my boss told me during my final
interview that she was nervous to hire
me because I haven't stayed at a job
longer than two years this was my third
job out of college I'm in my mid-20s I
told her just that I'm young I'd been
working my way up in the industry taking
new opportunities as they come to learn
as much as possible I did end up getting
the job but I've been waiting over a
year at this new job now
I've been waiting for it to become
exciting to me I feel very bored not
stimulated I just want I was just
offered a new job that is such an
amazing opportunity in my industry it
has a 20 pay increase for my current
role I really want to take the new
opportunity but I'm nervous for future
employers thinking that I can't stay at
a job for too long I don't want it to
reflect poorly on my resume I really
want to take this new opportunity but I
need your thoughts validation on taking
the new opportunities as such
established business women what are your
thoughts on this is it bad to like have
like to like hop around jobs obviously
three four five months are bad but like
a year yeah I didn't feel like that was
such a red flag but I do yeah if you're
hiring you know what her boss ended up
being right I actually was going to say
that like I feel like she's a little bit
right and so are you but if you're
hiring someone and you see they only
stay the job for like one two years even
though that feels like a long time it's
like I don't want to be hiring again for
this position right it's like I want
someone who's like going to grow with
the company now since you already have
another job lined up like I would say go
and take it because if you didn't have a
job I would say don't leave your job and
look for a job because yeah and the one
the two years one year and it does sound
a little bit like admittedly you're
always looking for like the next shiny
big thing yeah you're not easily
stimulated and it is a job like a job
and it's not always going to be exciting
and you thought this last opportunity a
year ago was going to be the opportunity
and now you have another one and I I now
I see maybe your boss was on to
something but if this is a better job
with a pay increase and you like I don't
see why and you already got it and you
already got it like I don't see why not
to do it and if you're worried about the
few the next job where thinking that you
are a short-term employee stay at this
next job for many years yes that and I
feel like you can always Finagle a
little bit the dates on your resume like
by like a couple months you know yeah
but a couple months like won't make a
big difference but I did think at first
like your boss was being like kind of
critical you're me too in your mid-20s
you're figuring yourself out two years
is a long time I agree it's not nothing
so but now I'm like oh maybe she's she
was onto something maybe she's a
soothsayer because yeah then you're
saying exactly what she was wearing
you're gonna say like it's not that that
interesting or stimulating Jackie's 100
right though like this isn't a problem
right now like you have a job offer you
got it with more money with a bigger
role so you take it but if you can
manage to stay at this particular job
for like three years I think you've
eradicated the problem yeah
yeah you like
I just I never know if it's like a good
or a bad thing if someone's resume has
like a million different jobs it's like
well were you the problem and like you
or
are you just like trying to snatch up as
much opportunity as possible you know
but it's good and it's bad yeah I think
that's a question you ask in an
interview and I think that there are
right answers and wrong answers you know
like you you are young maybe you're
still trying to find like exactly what
you want to do but then it leaves it
open to being like okay well maybe this
job isn't what you want to do either and
we're going to be screwed in a few
months yeah
um
but that's why there's references right
can't you call and ask past employers
yeah but also take the job take the job
unequivocally take the job take the job
but definitely keep this in the back of
your head like you don't want to be
perceived as like a homie hopper yeah
so I and I think honestly her giving you
that perspective is is really helpful
yeah because I would never have really
thought of that I mean either so take
the job congratulations
um and also realize like not every job
every day is going to be exciting and
stimulating and like
yeah a job is all of those things it's
important to always remember like you
don't you work for someone else like a
job is a means to an end it's how you go
on vacation and enjoy your life and go
out for drinks with your friends it is
not
for some people it is some people it's
their purpose but if it's not like that
is okay like having a nine-to-five job
that you don't love but that like
affords you the luxury to pay your rent
to live a life that you that's okay yeah
it's amazing when you find a passion but
I think people like look down on it if
you don't and I actually don't like if
you if your job just gets you by that is
a blessing and not everyone has that
like I think that's okay too yeah I
totally agree so don't forget that I
think if you're expecting something from
jobs in general
that might not ever come you're always
going to be like looking to the next and
the next and not just like blooming
where you're planted and being like
listen I have a good situation a salary
worth the most of it I'm not gonna you
know be finding my joy and my passion
and my
excitement here but that's okay in my
personal life and hobbies and side
hustles are for that's what five to nine
is for exactly yeah well take the job
congrats on your new job yeah and thank
you for writing into Deer toasters our
weekly advice segment will we do our
best to help girlies in need from work
from wedding from cheating things
there's no problem we can't solve no
crime we can't find by dinner time
somebody has started Drilling in the
unit next door so we're gonna wrap this
up thank you so much for listening to
the testimony morning everybody bye
I